rapper tyga spelled t-y-g-a kind of
pronounced like tiger but taiga deleted
his only fans account i saw on instagram
and started his own platform my star
with two y's just as i said would happen
remember on friday's show when i
mentioned that the top only fan creators
should just leave the platform and start
their own well they could do that and
just cut the fees apparently tyga is a
fan of the show here's my clip from
friday if the service can't do it
correctly shut it down and then the
people who are
uh the top performers on this service
should just make their own it's not hard
to replicate the service to be totally
honest the top hundred people should
just leave and make their own only fans
take back that 20 so there you have it
folks once again you heard the future
here just a little bit earlier and you
know what i can predict the future to a
certain extent on this podcast because i
talk to founders all the time and
sometimes you might wonder how did jason
know that a lot of times the reason i
know this because other founders are
calling me saying hey jkl i want to
start a competitor to that and then i
present it to you as a prediction when
in fact it's confidential information i
have so just know
that sometimes when i make a prediction
here it's because behind the scenes i
have a little bit of extra information
the founders who are likely to start
these things might tell me so sometimes
that is what's happening shortly after i
recorded on friday tyga tweeted the
following just leading my only fan
starting my own platform my star more
futuristic better quality and only a ten
fee obviously cut it in half creators
will also be able to make content of
their choice i think he's alluding to
adult entertainment as opposed to still
pictures i.e port and apparently apply
now to be the first to get an invite he
says my stars 10 cut is half of what
only fans takes so when a founder trips
and a company trips that's an
opportunity for other people to just
roll right over them and you know what
tyga is one of the top people on only
fans i understand so he's got a good
shot of doing that the tiger brand i
think is going to be bigger and
attractive to both entertainers on these
platforms and to the audience so
congratulations to him on building i
think what will be a billion dollar
company not my cup of tea i'm not going
to invest in it but if you have the
ability to invest in it i'm pretty
certain this will become a very good
investment the new platform will launch
in october coincidentally that's when
only fans will start banning explicit
conduct if you remember they're fine
with explicit content but not conduct in
other words you can be naked but you
can't be naked and having sex he has
over 23 million followers on instagram
and i've been saying over and over again
the top instagram creators or tick-tock
creators should leave and make their own
apparently here is an example of that
happening albeit on the adult side
according to my star's announcement
quote creators will have the ability to
sell nfts on the ethereum blockchain
what a brilliant idea
one of ones one of 50s just every piece
that only fans creator creates could
also go up in value and be sold wow you
get the membership fees and you get a
little bit of that nft pixie dust great
vision after the only fans news broke
last week competitive platforms have
tried to take advantage of the
opportunity and capture some of the
fleeing adult creators just for fans is
a similarly adult themed platform i told
by my researchers here and they released
the following statement on august 19th
the adult industry is sadly used to
companies cutting their teeth on the
adult market and then abandoning them
once they reach critical mass just for
dot fans was founded and built by and
for sex workers and its staff is 100
comprised of sex workers and people who
have been in the porn industry for many
years we are a porn site that will never
change and we just have no interest in
mainstreaming in quotes just for fans is
number two in traffic two only fans and
we are well poised to make sure adult
content creators are not abandoned we
welcome them
all to our website we believe we have
the most innovative platform out there
and are constantly evolving to meet the
needs of our community we welcome
everyone to check us out just for fans
followed up the statement with tips and
tools for how users can migrate large
amounts of content and data from one
platform to another and it appears
they've gotten a lot of traction with
migrating creators and users according
to my research team as they've been
tweeting about server migrations and
apologizing for crashes over the past
couple of days note just for fans takes
thirty percent of creative revenue which
is 10 higher than only fans and 20
percent higher than tyga's new platform
my star so i'm sure they will change
that according to the tos just for fans
it's a pretty unique referral model for
top accounts uh here's the quote select
members are allowed to make model
referrals signing up new models to the
system by a special link we provide they
will earn five percent of a model's net
earnings on subscriptions only for at
least one year with the likely potential
of the time period being extended but we
reserve the right to evaluate the
program after one year payments are made
on the first of every month for the
previous month chargebacks will be
debited accordingly so this is
interesting they're creating a
multi-level marketing adult
entertainment industry a program also
known as an affiliate program if this
was then
they got one percent of every model that
they brought in the systems referrals to
the system it would be a full-blown mary
kay cosmetics and as always we're seeing
massive innovation from the adult
entertainment uh industry
maybe this will all come to podcasting
at some point instead of listening to
this podcast you'll all have to pay and
then i'll turn you guys into podcasters
and take some of your money not likely
to happen we're doing very well with the
advertising sold out
i think we're sold out through november
and we just went to five days a week so
the podcast is doing great in fact we're
hiring another producer if you're
thinking
of getting into podcasting where you've
been in podcasting we're gonna hire our
fourth producer so there'll be seven
people on the team not counting myself
this podcast is doing really well
every startup needs business insurance
and you should look no further than a
broker if you don't have insurance you
failed one of the first steps in broker
technology saves you time and money
prices are up to 20 percent lower with
better coverage than the incumbents you
can go from sign up to quote and
purchase in just 10 minutes when you
work within broker instead of business
insurance incumbents you're not dealing
with large slow corporations plus the
sign up takes days not weeks and the
process is transparent with no opaque
pricing
here are four crucial types of startup
insurance that they cover and you're
gonna need all four of these in all
likelihood cyber insurance in case you
get hacked dno insurance so your if your
directors and officers do something dumb
and you get sued you're covered you have
eno insurance which covers errors and
omissions that's what the e and the o
stands for and it helps you scale
because many major customers will ask to
see your eno insurance in order to close
a deal and of course epl employment
practices liability discovers harassment
wrongful termination and more to
instantly buy custom built insurance for
startups go to inbroker.com twist
that's
e-m-b-r-o-k-e-r dot com
slash twist and while you're there get
an extra 10 off using the offer code
twist you guessed it okay let's get back
to this amazing episode